What?
Yeah, we did awesome!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Are you awake?
Mococo didn't mess up!
Right, Ruffians?
It starts!
Howl, howl, BAU BAU!
What did you say?
It's... I'm just thinking it's time!
Kirito wants more Moco-chan.
Wants more.
What's my place?
Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
We got it that time.
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I wonder if the Ruffians think we're fighting or something, huh?
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
Yeah.
It's the start of a new week.
You have to start it silly, right?
Maybe instead of starting on the right paw, this time it's the silly paw.
Maybe?
Well... Ruffians... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Well, I sure hope there's no first time Ruffians joining us today.
But... Maybe there is?
So I'll explain!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Maybe not the silly paw.
Yeah.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
No more silly stuff!
I don't know, I think there's a lot more silly to come still.
Have we been seeing Pero recently?
We haven't seen Pero, but some Ruffians have seen Pero.
So let's take a look!
De-den!
Nice hat.
Pero's back at the job site.
It seems like Pero might have gotten a bit bored with his daily life and decided to get his hands dirty and work at a steel shop.
Dangerous.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
We're glad to hear that Pero helped you out.
That was really nice of him!
Are you sure he wasn't just doing it because he was told to do it?
But maybe, maybe Pero liked the experience with the forklift.
You know, that one time.
So maybe he decided to branch out to a steel shop.
Oh, maybe.
Supervisor Pero!
Maybe not that far.
No, he's... not yet.
He has to work a bit harder first.
Pero's kind of our supervisor if you think about it.
No way.
You don't want him as your supervisor.
Well, we hope you have safe travels and that there are no bumps on the roads.
No big bumps.
There might be little bumps.
Ah, little bumps.
No big bumps.
BAU BAU!
Now, Ruffians!
Ruffians.
Did you miss it?
Well, you know, sometimes a weekend can be a busy time.
You've got a lot going on.
But...
Yesterday, we had a yummy... No, no, I'm Pero Sighting.
A yummy treat for Ruffians and Adventrix, a Halloween treat!
We had a new song cover come out together!
It's called Halloween Night Tonight.
It's actually our first song cover all together with Abyss!
It might sound a little bit familiar.
That's because it's an English version of our JP-senpai song,
Koyoiwa Halloween Night.
And the lyrics?
The English lyrics are done by Nerissa!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, the lyrics are super cute and catchy too.
They're really amazing.
Amazing!
Did you listen, Ruffians?
It's good!
Amazing!
You know, there's so many different parts and things being sung during the song, so... It's actually pretty difficult.
I'm thinking it was extra tricky.
Yeah, I think the hardest part for me is the... Because it's trick or treat.
Trick or treat, trick or treat night.
Trick or treat, trick and treat night.
Yeah.
And the rhythm's a bit like... Right?
It's tricky.
It turned out super cute though.
Yeah!
Ruffians liked it.
What was your favorite part?
I saw some Ruffians say that they liked the... It is a tongue twister.
It is, it is.
But it was really fun.
We put a lot of fun into our recording.
We did our best.
We tried to put a lot of personality into our voices.
I really really enjoy how everyone in Advent, we all have such different singing voices.
I really like the blend of us all together.
I think it makes our individuality stand out.
We hope that you listen to lots of this crazy howling!
Crazy party night!
If you don't, we'll just take a bite.
A bite.
A what?
Ruffians.
A bite.
Please listen, my fans!
Howl of a wing.
BAU-wing.
It's BAU-wing night.
Well, it wasn't just that, but we have something else very exciting too!
We also announced some new merch as part of our Advent Halloween Party!
Advent Apparel!
Thank you, Ruffians!
You know we have t-shirts and hoodies!
Not t-shirts.
You know the illustration... What?
Is that spooky BAU BAU?
It's spooky BAU BAU BAU.
I just thought it was a song.
But the illustrations!
They're done by Haiyu, you know what?
Did Kaibutsu too for us!
They're super cool, really spooky.
I look pretty cool, right?
Right, but I feel like Biboo's the most shocking, right?
I've never seen her make that face before.
I don't want to see it often.
Nope.
But Ruffians!
When you look at the illustrations, don't you feel a bit like you want to
BAU BAU to the moon!
But you can order them not to the hololive store I think you can as well. It depends on I think your country. But you can order them through Amazon.com. If you search up hololive production. And you know what?
Maybe they'll reach your paws even before Halloween Eve. Pretty fast. I don't know that fast. I don't know that fast.
BAU BAU BAU
Yeah, I think it depends on each person, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
But that's pretty fast.
But maybe it'll come pretty fast.
Pretty fast?
Did you order yours, Ruffians?
Did you?
Oh, it says Wednesday.
Wednesday!
So by the next FUWAMOCO Morning, you gotta have it.
Wait, really?
You got yours?
Yes!
What color did you get the hoodie in?
The pebble color?
The pebble color.
Maybe.
Waited!
BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Next, FUWAMOCO Morning.
And definitely Halloween, okay?
Definitely Halloween.
You know, even if you're not too much of the costume type person, then maybe you can show off how passionate you are for hololive and advent by wearing it!
Yeah, you know, if you came up to us and maybe asked for like a trick or treat while wearing it, we'd surely give you a treat, right?
Right, Moco-chan?
What are we waiting for?
A treat.
I guess.
Do you want to tweet, Ruffians?
No, I think I'll tweet this time.
BAU BAU!
Lots of exciting Halloween stuff's going on.
And we have some great news.
I don't know.
Ruffians.
The darkness, it continues to spread.
Our lightbulb situation has reached a critical point right now.
And so yesterday, we just couldn't take it anymore.
We need to see some light, get out of the darkness.
It's dark.
Yeah, so we decided to muster up the courage to change one key lightbulb.
We did it!
It was good!
Yeah!
We're really happy to have a bit more light back into our lives now.
But... But...
Actually, as soon as we changed that lightbulb, another lightbulb burnt out in our bath.
And you know, it's strange because I'm pretty sure we changed that one quite recently.
But it was sort of flickering strangely for a moment while I was drying my hair, and then suddenly... Dead.
It was just like...
And now we have to bathe in the darkness, Ruffians!
And what's worse is that it's a really scary lightbulb to fix.
Probably one of the worst.
I don't want to deal with it, but I also really don't like the darkness too.
I do find it a bit spooky that so many lightbulbs just keep on burning out though.
Right!
Why?
And all around the same time too.
Right!
Soon they'll all be gone.
Yeah, it's not like we leave our lights on all the time.
No!
But... It's nothing scary, right?
Not Halloween spirit.
Hopefully no more lightbulbs decide to die and leave us any further in the darkness.
Yeah.
Hopefully this is just contained to October.
The lights will come back on in November.
The lightbulbs will be like, hey, it's November, I'm fixed!
I was just taking a nap!
I was just napping, just a joke.
It's a prank.
That'll be good.
Which curse did you get?
What do you mean?
It's the lightbulb?
You're silly, Ruffians!
The lightbulb curse?
You're silly, okay?
Probably just an electrical thing?
I don't know.
I don't know, I feel like lightbulbs should be a little bit more resilient than this.
Right!
A little bit more brilliant.
Brilliant.
Brilliant and resilient.
I don't know how we're gonna fix this problem.
I don't know.
Ruffians, I have to tell you something.
It might expose Moco-chan, it might expose you a little bit.
It's pretty shocking.
It can't be helped.
I think I need to share this, but I'll say it!
I'll say it!
Ruffians, I'm gonna say it.
The other day, I caught Moco-chan trying to have a cup of tea.
Awful hot.
Yeah, but it was a bit funny looking.
I sorta look like a Rat King!
Like this!
Yeah!
Rat King tee!
Moco-chan, can you explain?
Ruffians, don't give me that look, okay?
Well, you know it!
When you have tea... No!
The first steep is really, really yummy and strong, right?
So, I think most people just sort of toss the teabag out after that.
Right?
But, I feel like it's a waste and that the teabag still has something in it.
So, I don't toss it.
I just, I keep them and dry them out in a separate bowl.
So then, when I have enough of them, I can save them up and then use them.
Again.
And the tea will be strong because it's a lot of tea bags.
Okay.
Why?
It's normal!
It's not normal.
But I guess it's time.
I saved up my tea bags for a while.
Quite a while.
Yeah, you did.
You did that.
I call it Wrecking Tea Ruffians because it had a billion bags of tea with strings dangling out of it.
Moco-chan usually uses a very big teacup.
I like a big teacup.
Even then it was filled to the max with teabags.
Before all the water.
Yeah.
And I stopped her, you know it.
I had to count just how many teabags were in her cup.
Can you guess how many teabag strings were dangling out of it?
This is normal size teabags, okay?
Yeah.
Ten?
No?
Twelve?
Nope.
Fifteen?
Almost!
Fourteen!
Fourteen bags of tea!
I saved it for a while.
It was gross.
They were all half-used, but even then, it looked like there was almost no room for liquid.
Moco-chan, why?
Just toss them away!
I don't want to waste them!
It's a waste!
It's gross.
I know, we are right Ruffians.
This is fine.
Were they mold?
Yeah, yeah, two weeks worth of them.
Yes, definitely only two weeks.
Not mold!
They dry out!
If they dry out, then it's fine!
It's not moldy!
Who's teabags mold?
That's weird.
They're just teabags in water.
They're not gonna mold, they just dry out.
I'm not putting milk on them or anything like that.
I don't know.
It's not weird, this is normal.
I'm being resourceful, okay?
Resourceful!
Do noga friends do this?
Maybe not.
FUWAMOCO-chan, maybe... I want to reappear into the Wraking T. I've done it too!
I'm gonna continue doing it, okay?
It's resourceful.
At least you have one friend.
Jonathan's your one friend.
Thank you!
Thank you for being on my side!
Okay, Jonathan?
Thank you!
Well... You still like me, right, Ruffians?
Right.
I like to say that things are gonna get a bit better.
What?
Ruffians, there's something... There's a misunderstanding.
Yeah.
You know the other day, we played the convenience store, right?
Right, right!
And after that, something funny happened.
Ruffians!
You started a hug pile!
Silly.
What?
Silly!
The Ruffians.
Why?
Well, it went on for over 30 minutes.
Right!
On top of that.
How long was it?
I think... I don't know.
It wasn't an hour, was it?
It was fun.
You enjoyed the dog pile.
What?
You missed the Ruffians hug play for 40 minutes?
44 minutes?
Exactly.
Wow.
But on top of that, it didn't just stop at hugging, really.
No.
Some Ruffians might think that us, FUWAMOCO, that we're particularly fond of kisses on the paw, but that's... That's too bold, Ruffians!
It makes us embarrassed, okay?
You're gonna break our brains like that, okay?
You can't just be like Oscar from Rose of Versailles or some other suave shoujo manga sweetheart, okay?
It's too much.
You'll make them blush too much.
Ruffians.
Head pat.
Yes.
But no touching the ears, okay?
No, no, no.
No touching the tail.
Got it.
Tummy rubs, tummy rubs.
When it's scary and my tummy hurts, I guess.
Maybe.
But, you know, a hug pile doesn't hurt anyone, but... Kisses on the paw.
It's Monday!
Ruffians, it's Monday!
And that means it's a new week!
A new week!
It's Monday.
It's time!
Moco-chan!
You know, it's time to challenge something new.
I was thinking, the Ruffians, they don't necessarily need to challenge Naito, but if they want something extra challenging, they could challenge a haunted house.
You know, make yourself stronger that way.
Moco-chan, I was wondering, would you prefer to go through a haunted house or try a natto?
Huh?
Natto.
Yeah.
I feel like there's more benefits overall.
Right, right.
You know, good health benefits, whereas a haunted house would likely give me a heart attack.
Yeah.
And well, Moco-chan's gonna do her best to give the Ruffians some inspiration today, but...
Eating more natto!
Eating it.
I say by eating more natto, but we're still at the starting point.
That's okay!
Well, despite being at the starting point, today is Moco-chan's seventh time trying to eat it on FUWAMOCO Morning.
And I'm kind of starting to feel like maybe I should stop counting because it's just getting embarrassing.
But!
But for Ruffians that maybe don't know what natto is, natto is a common breakfast food in Japan and it's made of fermented soybeans.
But...
It's a bit sticky, it's a bit slimy, a bit strong smelling, but it's really healthy for you.
And you know, so Moco-chan, you're going to conquer your fear, your dislike for it.
My fear?
I don't think I fear it.
I'm just not good with it.
I don't know, but... Today is the day!
This way you can, you know, protect the Ruffian smile for many, many years to come and be a bit stronger like your older sister, right?
Today!
How is your confidence today, Moco-chan?
I... I had a lot of... I had a lot of nightmares last night.
So, I don't feel the best.
But, I feel... Like I wanna do it.
Why?
Because the dreams were scary, so now you're like... I'm gonna eat it!
I'll do it for the Ruffians.
I feel...
I feel like I'm gonna do my best, even though I had bad dreams.
Well, today... Can you actually eat it?
I'm gonna try.
Consume it!
I have a bunch of tissues, but I swear to feel!
Like, maybe.
Huh?
Maybe.
I can do it.
I don't need the tissues.
We properly received the nutrients today, finally!
I can't tell yet.
Please do it.
Okay, Moco-chan!
First, let's say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi who worked very hard to make this.
Thank you!
It's all ready!
Moco-chan took it with confidence, I feel like, this time.
I did, but now I'm doubting myself.
I received the Bacillus.
What?!
Thank you for the hemp pints!
I guess you can use that now, huh?
Oh, it's so sticky.
It looks particularly yummy today.
It looks... What was that?
I got hit in the face with the smell.
It's like a wall.
I didn't stir it up too much.
You didn't, you didn't.
It's only half fluffy.
Only half fluffy.
I'm looking for a not very fluffy, sticky, slimy one, but I feel like I'm not choosing the best.
They still are.
Pick two, Moco-chan.
No, I'm going to try four.
Actually, you should try four because we're going to be collabing with Fubuki-senpai and Poruru-oneechan, right?
But I'm going to do my best today.
I had a lot of nightmares.
So I woke up early early.
Because I figured, I had nightmares.
If I go back to sleep, I'm going to have more nightmares.
So I'm just going to wake up early and do stuff.
A little sister?
You know what would be even a better little sister?
What?
If you ate your natto.
Eat your natto, okay?
Okay, I'm gonna try, okay?
I don't need a countdown.
It'll be okay without it.
I'm gonna do it without it, okay?
Gross!
I'm gonna do it without it.
Moco-chan, you're growing!
Today, my plan is to chew it.
Okay?
I'm gonna chew it in the molars.
Okay, that's my decision.
With the cane eyes!
I'm not gonna say anything, I'm just focused.
Okay, focus.
I'm waiting.
Do it!
Oh, oh, she did it!
She did it!
Oh, I don't see the fear.
Oh, it's going well.
Oh, oh, the face is only a little bit sad.
I did it.
She did it!
Ruffians!
Moco-chan, Moco-chan, show me your tummy.
My sister ate the natto!
I need the water!
One bean.
One bean, you ate it!
Okay, next bean.
Next bean.
The seventh time and Moco-chan finally did it!
Now do a second one, right?
Second one, second time.
I'm getting used to the taste on my molar.
It worked.
Maybe nightmares... Nightmares is the key.
I did it, okay?
Even though I had nightmares.
Okay.
You can do it too, Ruffians, okay?
You're inspired now.
Moco-chan, you should try another.
Try another.
You can do it.
You're strong!
No, a strong goat!
I did one, next time I'll do two.
Next time I'll do two, you'll eat it.
I want the Ruffians to leave inspired, okay?
Do you feel powerful?
What's your thoughts?
Maybe I'm getting used to the taste.
Can you feel it?
I noticed it in your tummy.
My tummy hurt a bit.
Wait, I'm getting used to it, maybe.
Good job, Moco-chan!
That was a really, really good attempt.
Next time!
Definitely, too, if not before.
But, Ruffians, let's remember to...
Remember Moco-chan's best attempt to eat the natto today?
Which is today, my best attempt, right?
Getting stronger, right?
Let's use that to power ourselves through the rest of the week.
BAU BAU!
Now for our Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... DoDo the Husky!
She's a cutie!
She's very cute, very dramatic.
She likes to make a lot of funny expressions.
I like her sort of side eye.
When you're taking a photo of her.
But yeah, we can definitely see she likes the funny expressions.
She's cute.
She's fluffy.
She looks very fuzzy.
In between the ears is very fuzzy.
But, you know, she does look a little bit grumpy here on the floor, right?
Moco-chan, why do you think she could be pouting?
Maybe it's chilly on the floor.
Chilly?
Maybe she'd rather be on your lap.
But she's not small.
No, she's not gonna fit there.
I don't know.
I was thinking that maybe Dodo ate a shoe.
Or in trouble.
Never!
She's good.
How does Dordo BAU BAU?
A big husky BAU BAU?
I guess like... Just like that, I'm sure.
I'm sure.
Good singing, huh?
Ups and downs, right?
Yeah, just like you said, Dodo has ups and downs, you know?
Everyone does, right?
She keeps us entertained with her silly expressions though!
And because she's so emotive, it's easy to tell just by looking at her how much she loves them.
BAU BAU!
We have another.
Today I went on a walk.
Why did this Ruffian go for a walk?
Let's see.
De-den!
A good snack.
This Ruffian is in Japan.
Decided to stop by Miso-do for the first part of the day.
What does it say there?
Not sure if it's as good as advertised by the demon dogs.
Hi!
Excuse me!
What are you talking about, huh?
It's a pon-de-ring, okay?
A pon-de-ring!
What do you mean by not good?
It's delicious.
It's stretchy.
It's fluffy and fuzzy.
It's perfectly sweet.
You know, maybe it's just that your taste buds are broken.
Huh, Ruffian?
Maybe you're the problem.
But, you know, it's good that you got out.
I would say that I hope you enjoyed your walk more than the pon-de-ring, but that's pretty hard competition.
That's pretty rude, huh?
Yeah, pon-de-ring's are just too good, you know.
But, maybe, maybe soon things will be a bit better and your taste buds will be fixed soon.
Let's hope for that, okay?
Enjoy Japan!
BAU BAU!
For our Question of the Day, we have... Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
In the first Resident Evil scene, Mococo mentions you could hear noises coming from everywhere.
Does that mean Fuwawa and Mococo use separate headphones or earphones when streaming?
How do you set something like that up?
I think for Resident Evil, I can hear things from everywhere because it's coming from everywhere and I'm very scared.
Yeah, maybe it's a little Moco-chan kind of thing, but I've actually seen a number of Ruffians asking this question.
Well, a quick answer is that we do use separate headphones.
Moco-chan's ears are shorter and rounder than mine, and mine are bigger and taller, right?
It's a bit different.
Yeah, it's kind of hard to share headphones or earbuds.
Sometimes we do, but not in this case.
Nooo!
Yeah, like we said, it's a bit different, especially I guess, compared to all of Advent at least.
But you know, it's a really strong and powerful sound, so we want to learn how to master it, but... Yeah!
I don't know, I think that we've done a pretty good job so far.
Pretty good, yeah.
You know, tech stuff is difficult.
It's difficult.
Sometimes I need to give it a little bit of a... BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Yeah, so... Deserves it sometimes.
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream, there's always a next stream right around the corner.
This time, we have... De-den!
We have a collab together with Fubuki-senpai and Pororo-chan!
Yeah!
And we're going ghost hunting in 5-4-4-3!
Like we mentioned just before.
Yeah.
Alright.
You know, Fubuki-senpai was so brave and strong when she showed us through the back rooms, right?
Showed us through the back rooms.
Kind of like showing us through the... But, I think she's probably pretty strong at ghost hunting too.
Will Fubuki-senpai even scream?
I don't think so.
I've sneezed already over 15 times this morning.
She has.
But to continue though, do we think Poruru-oneechan will be a bit scared?
Is she a scaredy cat like us?
It could go either way.
Well, even if she is, you know, I think we gotta show how we're strong.
We're gonna be strong.
Just like yesterday.
Maybe we should try not to hide in the closet so much.
Yeah, because we were definitely very strong during paranormal cleanup, right?
Yeah.
We're gonna make ourselves very proud being like, yeah, this is my kouhai!
Please, please, please, be there for us.
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
It's a busy, busy week.
And we have a bunch of exciting collabs this week as we approach Halloween.
Fuki.
Fuki times.
But we're gonna be finishing off
Home Sweet Home with Bijou on Saturday!
Hopefully!
What was that pause?
It was a hopeful pause.
Really it wasn't.
You think of how scary it was.
Hopefully.
We'll be finishing it.
So please come and help us get past all the spooky tiger wisdom.
Rescue our cute wife Jane!
Jane!
I want to save Jane!
I feel like we're so close to solving the mystery.
I can feel it.
I can feel it, Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for a very silly FUWAMOCO Morning.
A very celebratory one.
Celebratory!
Moco-chan, finally, you finally ate your first natto bean.
I've eaten one before.
I don't know.
This was the first time, no?
No!
I did it for Poruru-oneechan.
Really?
I feel like every time it's always in the tissue.
No, this was my second time.
Is it Ruffians?
Ruffians, you know, right?
Seiken Naito.
Thank you.
I forgot.
Well, Ruffians, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Yeah!
Bellini!
BAU BAU!
Mr. BAU BAU!
Annie!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, BAU BAU?
Benjamin!
BAU BAU!
Disco King!
Kougel!
BAU BAU!
Cocasso!
Dumpfish!
BAU BAU!
Jacob Hunter.
Moomoo.
BAU BAU!
Twig Cycle Shopping.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU!
BAU BAU!
I almost did the same thing as you did at the beginning, huh?
What?
BAU BAU!